c'est pas son lent sa démarche saccadée
ces gestes rigide christiane tente tant
bien que mal de se balader dans son beau
jardin qu'elles peinent aujourd'hui à
entretenir
à 72 ans christiane zita est atteinte de
la maladie de parkinson une maladie qui
affecte progressivement ses mouvements
c'est un journée que j'ai crié
seul un projet de sémalens passe-t-il à
petit parce que je travaillais dans le
social
j'avais besoin d'un simple pour ma
détente mais là maintenant je peux plus
rien faire
ça fait mal dans ces des fois je prends
quelqu'un pour m'aider mais je vois que
ça ça part tout doucement à vau l'eau
tellement ce qui était d'une simplicité
auparavant comme monter les escaliers
est désormais un véritable parcours du
combattant
les chutes sont fréquentes christiane
perd rapidement l'équilibré
les gestes du quotidien lui demande
alors un effort colossal
j'ai trouvé beaucoup de chance mais je
peux faire 15 minutes ans après il faut
que j'aille me coucher
la maladie de parkinson affecte son
système nerveux central
une pathologie neurodégénérative qui
déclenche la disparition irréversible
des neurones le diagnostic de christiane
a été tardif
au début les symptômes sont souvent
confondus avec ceux du vieillissement
normal je pense que j'ai commencé à
trembler depuis 2006 même peu avant 2015
et puis après 2009 j'ai un petit avc
j'avais beaucoup de douleurs à la tête
et le 1er juin 2013
je suis tombé dans la journée on est
malade
mais ce qui m'a fait le plus de mal
c'est d'avoir perdu la capacité des
clients
ce qui vous êtes
oui j'ai passé ma vie à écrire
apprivoiser la pathologie composé vivre
avec elle pour ne pas qu'elles
envahissent davantage le corps et
l'esprit
cristiano début révoltés ne s'est à
aucun moment résigné ancenis
quand je me regarde je me désole mais
quand je me compare je me console ans on
voit que les gens qui sont mieux mais il
ya déjà moins bien et on se dit ça ça me
botte un peu pour aller aux ateliers
faire les soins pour ne pas dégénérer
trop vite
la maladie de parkinson est la deuxième
maladie neuro dégénérative la plus
fréquente après la maladie d'alzheimer
en martinique ils sont plus d'un millier
à vivre avec